sur canal à partir du 15 juillet
je
ah bravo ça quel bonheur voilà ils ont
bien la paix c'est pour ça comment tu
veux j'en parle faut regarder regarder
cette émission vaut vraiment le coup les
mecs qu'ils ont c'est ce qui serait bien
là les mecs soient là en train
d'attendre que tu les fasse venir et
qu'on les voit là tout de suite ça comme
ça ça n'est pas précisé la ministre
et
vous présente au comedy club
alors
présentez-vous les uns après les autres
commencent parfois
voir
le chômage des jeunes qui est qu'il
avait pas fait ce métier serait
dictateur dans son pays c'est sur sa
mesure oui on avait besoin d'une blanche
alors on la fait rire bien jouer tu
t'appelles comment blanches ail blanc
hamel enfin fabrice patson jahl d'edo
qui voit litre de sang humain par jour
et ça me dit le comte de bouderbala
on peut vous aurez le privilège de
retrouver cet été sur canal + j'espère
vous serez nombreux à regarder cette
émission a vaut le coup
j'ai juste profiter de l'occasion c'est
vrai c'est la dernière tu m'as tu m'as
vraiment moi pour ma part du service
avec ses missions et je voulais vous
remercier tous les deux pour cent faite
ou encore jamel et le moment
jamais que les producteurs de jamel
comedy club mais aussi d' indigènes
le film de rachid